48 horas después de la marcha por la
vida Cara que este domingo convocó a más
de 30.000 personas en París los
franceses nuevamente salieron hoy a las
calles para protestar en contra de la
situación económica el costo de la vida
y las medidas tomadas por el gobierno de
Manuel macron concretamente estaban
convocados por cuatro sindicatos más a
la izquierda encabezados por la cgt
justamente aquellos que siguen con la
huelga en las refinerías y depósitos que
tiene a un 25% del país sin combustible
la marcha se desarrolló de manera
bastante tranquila hasta que un grupo de
encapuchados se puso delante del cortejo
cerca de 300 personas y tuvo varios
enfrentamientos con la policía sin
embargo la marcha terminó de manera
pacífica lo que más afecta a las
personas es que el gobierno haya
intervenido los depósitos y las
refinerías para obligar a los
trabajadores a realizar sus labores en
vista de esta huelga por combustibles
Ellos dicen que eso atenta contra el
histórico derecho a huelga en Francia
Mientras tanto el gobierno ha pasado la
responsabilidad los empresarios les ha
pedido que aumenten los salarios Incluso
el ministro del interior dijo que aquí
había un problema de sueldo el
presidente Manuel macrón se ha reunido
con suministros ayer pero él no va a
tomar en ninguna medida al respecto de
los salarios sin embargo ha prometido a
los franceses que están sufriendo dijo
él con esta huelga de los combustibles
tratar de normalizar la situación lo más
pronto posible